ich stellte kurz die kamera denn jetzt
muss man hier nämlich wasser wäre das
mache ich nicht dass man sieht dass hier
rein und jetzt passt überhaupt das geht
nicht ab wo ich was geht ab herzlich
willkommen bei einem neuen video wollte
heute geht es mal wieder um eine meiner
lieblingsbeschäftigungen und zwar
produkte auspacken und ausprobieren ich
habe für diese woche auf jeden fall
wieder einige coole videos geplant ist
müssen noch mega viele amazon produkte
ankommen die auf jeden fall interessant
werden ich habe ja in den letzten videos
schon gesagt das ist jetzt immer öfter
irgendwas gibt wird man halt sachen
bestellt oder ich halt sachen bestellen
die auspacke so wie früher das ganze mit
den wachen nur dann bis jetzt
professioneller sag ich mal und das
video heute möchte ich ungelogen
wirklich schon seit fünf monaten machen
ich habe allerdings immer so ein
bisschen aufgeschoben weil ich dachte
ist das jetzt so coole da ist es nicht
so cool ich habe ungefähr fünf monaten
im märchen der mystery box bayerisch
gekauft irgendwie dass falls nichts
besonders ja irgendwie 18 dollar
gekostet oder so man muss auch wirklich
immer lange suchen bis man da irgendwas
findet falls sie jetzt wieder noch nicht
gesehen habe dass ich auf jeden fall
hier noch an und ich habe gleichzeitig
auch irgendwie so eine juden mystery box
bestellt also you missed eine ähnliche
seite which da kann man halt auch so
krims krams bestellen bis nur ein
bisschen schneller mit dem versand und
auch kostenlos das ding hat auch
irgendwie 15 dollar gekostet oder so ich
weiß es nicht mehr es ist halt schon
fünf monate her ab und ich habe hier so
ein riesen karton also so groß war dass
jetzt nicht diese jugend box die war
vielleicht keine ahnung so roos ich hab
nur irgendwann mein zimmer aufgeräumt
und die stand halt noch rum und dann
habe ich alle sachen hier eingeliefert
weil ich da halt irgendwie so eigentums
krams reinhauen den ich nicht mehr
brauche weil ich will eigentlich davon
ausgegangen bin eine dieses video keine
ahnung wenn das du noch mal irgendwann
macht und hast du die sachen hier drin
also das meiste davon habe ich schon
gesehen ich habe allerdings nicht mehr
wirklich schlagen das ist jetzt auch
schon drei monate
oder so gut so viel zur erklärung also
es geht heute um eine you missed the box
und ich würde sagen wir lagern gar nicht
lange gestellt das ganze mal nach ihr
und wieder anfangen sofort mal anders
müssten ja keine ahnung vielleicht zehn
sachen seien irgendwelche ideen für
weitere bestellung des videos natürlich
und in die kommentare das ist mir ganz
wichtig und die kann ich dann hier in
diesem wunderschönen corp sammeln der in
dieser wunderschönen box anscheinend
drin war also schon gesagt erwartet
jetzt nichts mega besonderes das ding
war nicht teuer
wir haben allerdings mit schönen corp da
kann man ganz gut stifterin sammeln oder
was auch immer tun so als heute
ich habe eine vermutung und zwar haben
wir hier finde ich eigentlich ganz geil
so das ding ist ich habe deshalb viel zu
spät geöffnet glaube ich ich suche mir
ein bisschen mehr an keeper hätte ich
dieses ding bei der fußball wäre schon
gehabt dann wäre vielleicht deutschland
ein bisschen weiter gekommen war ja
nicht so dolle dieses jahr
ich verstehe auch warum dieses produkt
da drin ist ich habe das glaube ich
warte mal ja so im mai bestellt das war
vor der fussball werden da haben sie
wahrscheinlich gedacht hey oder das ding
behalten rüberkommen schmeißt man das
noch da rein auf jeden fall danke weiß
ich ja auf jeden fall viel mit
anzufangen nicht wahr weil es das
nächste produkt freue ich mich auch ganz
besonders wir haben hier das ist dass
leute hier kann man anscheinend
irgendwie rein schreiben und kann man
sagen verschicken oder so ich hab kein
plan ist auch wirklich gut für meine
ganzen die pferdefreunde da da kann ich
hier so schönen brief schreiben versteht
ich dann und wie werden sie sich
sicherlich freuen aber das ganze geht ja
noch ein bisschen
ich sehe auch schon eine sache die habe
ich früher so gefallen hat wir machen
einfach hier mit weiter das ist sieht
aus wie eine leicht und zwar haben wir
hier ein
was soll das sein ein dinosaurier
das versuche ich jetzt mal zu öffnen ist
gar nicht mal so leicht wie man denkt
ach das ist schlimm oder
hieran wird man auf jeden fall dass es
nicht mehr ganz frisch ist und dass da
wahrscheinlich jetzt zeit wirklich schon
fünf monate so rum das ist schlimm den
muss man alters geht das ist schaut euch
das mal oder knete das kann nicht nur
alter ja das ist bis jetzt auf jeden
fall das geld herkommen das kann man
dann wahrscheinlich ja gehen ja schleife
ist ja weiß was auf youtube total in ist
verstehe ich absolut nicht was an so was
toll sein soll aber gut letztens habe
ich mal gefragt was richtet noch für
videos machen soll und eben wie so ein
top kommentare macht doch mal schleim
das haben doch schon gefühlt eine
million menschen immer gesagt dass mir
bitte kurz in den kommentaren was ist
daran so toll verstehe ich absolut nicht
also da finde ich so was ist denn da der
grösste mühe drin ist 1000 mal spannende
leute was ich auch gar nicht mal
schlecht finde dein t-shirt ja wir haben
hier nun sogar nl ungefähr meine größe
also t shirts trage ich sowieso nl und
schlicht weiß ja nicht
also es hat noch diesen gewissen starken
intensiven geruch der allerdings ein
bisschen verflogen ist jetzt über die
monat wird nur das ist bis jetzt auf
jeden fall das beste vor allem ein t
shirt kostet auch wirklich eigentlich 34
euro also lang auf jeden fall leute als
nächstes haben wir hier eine geniale
flöte das war ja früher wirklich so ein
trend hat irgendwie jedes mädchen flöte
gespielt
gut also also wirklich halt eine
musikalische flöte ich würde mal sagen
alle die von euch früher im flötenkurs
waren schreiben jetzt mal in die
kommentare hashtag flöte ich war auf
jeden fall auch in köthen kurs ich zeige
euch mal kurz an ihn falsch rum
ja danke für die flöte
ich glaube wenn ich jetzt mal so an
meine ganzen mystery boxmark denke ich
hatte noch keine einzige wo ich gesagt
habe
das sind jetzt wirklich geile sache aber
gut man so schnell ist immer wieder eine
sache die sich schon die ganze zeit die
finde ich auf jeden fall freue ich mich
am ende
wir machen weiter mit einer trinkflasche
und das bin ich wirklich spannend wirds
da an haussler reingeht ob die jetzt so
sie gehen jetzt gut ist mit diesem
plastik weiß ich nicht aber das ist wohl
zum travel also reisen das mache ich ja
unfassbar gerne deswegen scheiße na
super weil ich habe ich das mal wenn ich
das hier oben auch machen will
es ist kaputt ich mache ihn noch kurz
ein bisschen wasser rein kommt man mit
und wer ist hier aber das geht gar nicht
dabei also diese trinkflasche pnp nicht
zu empfehlen
man drückt hier und alles fließt aus und
das ist schon kaputt einer rastenden
dreck ja wunderbar das video das t shirt
haben
um das gleich wieder aufzurichten ich
meine ist ja nur was nach so wir machen
weiter und kommen ja das ist irgendwie
auch immer dabei eine cap von der marke
classics jugend aufruhr um gehört sitzt
wahrscheinlich extrem gut da da man kann
ich auf jeden fall raus gehen ja sie
haben wir einen cap in dunkelbraun
eigentlich auch gar nicht mal so
schlecht kostet auch im einkauf
sicherlich zwei euro wollte
wahrscheinlich keiner haben da kann ich
mir gut vorstellen so leute und jetzt
passt auf ich habe diese teile früher
geliebt im urlaub war ich immer so wenn
ich ganz viele davon hatte und zwar
haben wir hier eine pistole eine
wasserpistole und die sind wirklich halt
gut also die spritzen schon ordentlich
weitere was aber auch mit der
zweideutigkeit
hier steht auch mini eliminator ja ich
würde sagen
das auf jeden fall noch getestet finde
ich wirklich richtig cool wenn ihr die
teile kennt lass es mich gerne in den
kommentaren wissen dass sie auch mal
seine in jedem pack ich glaube ich habe
jetzt schon gefühlt 20 sonnenbrille von
denen nur zwei gut sind ja wir haben
wieder eine sonnenbrille
wobei man auch sagen aus dem letzten
teil die kostenlosen milchprodukte war
wirklich eine gute sonnenbrille dabei
was ich jetzt von dieser halten weiß ich
nicht was ihr sagt herr alex sie steht
dir super hebt den daumen nach oben
schaffte heute wahrscheinlich nicht mal
1000 reichswehr was das darin soll weiß
ich auch nicht es sind wo es sind sogar
zwei strumpfhosen für babys ist auf
jeden fall nicht besonders gut wir
testen mal kurz die reißfestigkeit ich
willst du was glaube ich er ist wie
lange geht das denn spitze was glaube
ich eher als nur benutzen oder so weiß
ich auch unglaublich viel mit anzufangen
danke für diese schönen strumpfhosen und
eine sache hier haben wir noch bevor das
coolste kommt und zwar ja seifenblase
aus italien jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
ob das besser ist als diese wie man halt
aus deutschland
[Musik]
also habe ich auch als kind gerade
gekommen erkennt man ein video machen
zehn produkte die man als kind geliebt
hat oder die man früher immer haben
wollte falls ja schreibt gern mal
produkte dazu in die kommentare und
jetzt kommen wir zum absoluten finale
für sich wirklich gut getroffen haben
ist dieses tennis etwa zum tennisspielen
nein wir haben hier wirklich einen 4
port said und hier war ich wirklich
überrascht das wusste ich ja auch noch
was ist da drin ist aber wer rechnet
bitte mit so was in so einem mist
reading das ist eigentlich ein
klassischer wo ich sagen
damit kann ich auch kinder was anfangen
sollte es irgend wer von euch nicht weiß
was man damit macht man stellt hier die
blätter auf denen die beiden bäcker oder
eigentlich viel mehr besser kommt ein
mineralwasser und dann muss das
gegnerische team versuchen diese besser
zu treffen so treffer und dann wird halt
ausgetrunken also wirklich geil hier
muss ich sagen geil ja leute das war's
noch leider schon gehören da glaube ich
insgesamt so 10 sachen gehabt gar nicht
mal schlecht der beschwerden kann man
sich da auf jeden fall nicht für 12 oder
15 euro ich habe keinen plan merck das
war die junge ist die box die ich halt
vor einem halben jahr oder so gestellt
habt also jetzt gehe ich kurz darauf
sparen zeit war wie viel power seinen
teil hat falls ihr das nicht kennen
sonst würde schon mal sagen ab und nicht
vergessen locker aktivieren und wir
sehen uns morgen ja da gibt es ein neues
cooles video
man sieht dass hier rein und jetzt passt
mal auf das geht wenig ab wo also die
dinger spritzen wirklich 10 15
mitarbeiter also ich muss sagen
dankeschön für dieses nette teil
also leute das war's fast rein ins
rollen